I met Donald Sutherland six years ago on
the Hunger Games I was young and I know
stay professional but Donald was Donald
is the most committed professional kind
person I had ever met I don't know why
he took me under his wing the way he did
he sent me a box of 50 books one of
which came to be my favorite book of all
time Anna Karenina and between takes he
asked me questions and gently gave me
guidance I will never forget his
generosity for someone so generous and
talented it's odd to think that Donald
Sutherland has never won an Oscar before
tonight a dirty dozen mash the invasion
of the body snatchers Kelly's heroes
don't look now the day of the locust
Clute six degrees of separation ordinary
people iconic roles from an
extraordinary actor seemingly without
effort in the space of two or three
films he can plumb the depths of despair
and loss portraying the greatest tragedy
imaginable the loss of a child and then
the next time he saw him he'd be a rebel
or a clown with an irrepressible
mischievous wit and there is no role of
any size even the smallest and which
Donald was not capable of demanding your
attention and in a matter of moments
becoming the best and most memorable
thing about the movie Donald has not
only made his characters fascinating no
matter what they're doing he's made his
movies and the movies of his time worth
watching even when you study his work
carefully you can you can't quite see
exactly how he does it Donald
Sutherlands work is movie magic at its
best
once on the set of a big film the lead
who was a pretty famous actor told the
director he didn't think he should have
the role he said he felt the lead to go
to an American the director looked
around the set and says to Donald hey
you you have big ears you should play
the general and that was the Dirty Dozen
after this exit success of that film
Donald was asked to meet Ingo Pro and
from anger
grand mal Joe who was producing a
little-known movie called mash I wrote
this myself I really don't know I just
don't know his name when Dylan went in
to meet on the roll he was so nervous he
was practically shaking he was so
worried he wasn't going to get the part
he sits down to meet Ingo and he goes
says you were really great in that movie
and the Dirty Dozen and Donald's exhales
with relief and then Ingo pauses and
says well it could have been the
director his son rogue shared a story
with me when shooting the dry white
season he uprooted the family to
Zimbabwe
Donald was up early as always to shower
and the phone rang
rogue answered and the ad told him that
Donald wasn't needed at work that day
because mr. Brando wasn't able to shoot
that day
rogue passed along the message to his
dad who said until I can do that myself
I am nothing well at 82 years old he has
never missed a call time he is always
the first one to set and has famously
rewritten the dialog of all of his
scenes before the director has even
arrived on set much to their dismay he
is honestly and truly something else
which is why I am so proud to be here if
we had an honor a knighthood I think
he'd be Sir Donald Sir Sutherland that
is an honor to present this overdue
Oscar to a great magician a phenomenal
actor a wonderful role model and a
terrific human being with an enviable an
impressive body of work the great Donald
Sutherland
[Applause]